crazy quilt eraser polka dot man
mine tarantula king cut orca killer ma
orange harriet zodiac master gentleman
ghost clock key calendar man
kite man catman zebra man and the
condiment key
okay are you making some of those up
nope they're all real
probably worth the google
[Music]
oh pretty i want it
hey you can't do that sure i can lady
i'm the pack rat and your trash is my
treasure hey
hmm
security
oh no you don't
you always wanted to escape the shadow
of the bat robin
here's your chance you're gonna wish you
stayed in arkham with your coloring
[Music]
books
i'm going to weave you both into carpets
and spend the rest of my life
walking all over you
call me a coward now you little runt
quilt we gotta go
who's laughing now little birdie
who's laughing now
[Music]
quilt the cops
[Applause]
[Music]
that was a slimy trick you rotten egg of
course batgirl i have a patent on slimy
tricks
wait a minute where is malenko
batman he was probably too afraid of me
to show up
only these foolhardy youngsters are
impolitic enough to do
that
[Music]
give it up fugit hill committed no crime
against you he did worse
he made me late
[Music]
[Music]
ah i could do this all day batman
but your time is up
[Music]
heads up showhounds drop your forks and
prepare to cower before the
[Music]
hey hey i don't believe this
i say coward and you're still eating
well all right then
now see here
[Music]
hot sauce anyone else want to be a hero
then take out your wallets cash and
jewels and toss them here on the table
come on right now
we are pleased to inform you that phase
one of our royal master plan has
succeeded as prophesied
hey that's great boss i mean your royal
highness
phase two will now be put into being
are there any questions i got one you
may speak royal scrivener
like why i mean why did that hunk a rock
in the park and tip off the suckers what
we're gonna do
you're a twin
it's merely a sovereign subterfuge to
exterminate a winged
rodent once and for all batman
he should be biting at the bait about
now
oh boy all hail
to king tut great thorn of thieves
nemesis of the nile
[Music]
thank you greg thank you it was
delightfully spoken
calendar man now if 30 days have
september
batman but how i hadn't even begun my
new holiday crime spree
i'll explain later take a dive
uh oh
there i defeated your villain of choice
now will you go home
whoa whoa that was never a fair fight
you've got skills and weapons
all he's got is a daily planner let's
bump him up a notch
calendar man you are now calendar king
with the power to bring any holiday icon
to life
really live the dream big shot
yes i'll take an army of halloween
jack-o'-lanterns
a legion of biker santas
and a company of uber patriotic uncle
sand
happy holidays batman
here comes bastard begging for scraps
[Music]
bad boy buster go away
hey guess what's today anybody know
oh come on guess
you mean you had us brought here just so
you could throw yourself
a surprise party that's it i always knew
you were a selfish little brat
always throwing your temper tantrums and
making life miserable for the rest of us
well this time you've gone too far
expect a call from my
lawyer
[Music]
yeah todd
lizzy miriam's a treasure i couldn't get
through the day without hers
[Music]
you're not my daughter and we're not a
family
we're actors remember you cancel our
show because you whined you weren't
getting enough attention
but i knows now i made a boo-boo
you